Sam's with us in Wisconsin hi Sam
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you how can I help so a little bit of a
unique situation my wife and I are on
our second home that we purchased from
her parents and her dad so graciously
allowed us to purchase it from him and
he is our bank and it is a 0% interest
land contract that he is actually
covering the taxes on so we're in a
great situation but my question for you
today as we are looking at really
starting to invest I'm trying to weigh
what would be a better return on our
money whether that would be to simply
pay off our is your percentage interest
mortgage as fast as we can or to do a
little bit of both of investing and
while paying off our mortgage we suggest
when you're debt-free everything but the
mortgage that your next step is to have
an emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses we call that baby step 3
do you have an emergency fund uh we do
but I know that it's not as much as we
should have okay the first thing before
we talk about in this other stuff is it
should be three to six months of
household expenses in liquid cash that
you don't touch for any reason this is
not a Hana saving up for Christmas or
vacation or a house or anything else
this is a an emergency fund the
government then once you've done that
then we do baby steps four five and six
at the same time but in that order of
priority four is 15% of your household
income going into retirement and that
would be matching 401 k's roth iras you
know traditionals whatever along those
lines and you're filling up stuff in
good mutual funds there and what's your
household income household income is
about seventy five thousand dollars
combined a year okay all right and so
you know we're talking about about
$9,000 a year roughly is your is fifteen
percent of your income everything above
that then leaves us for baby step five
which
kids college you have any kids that you
need to say for college we have one so
far we're in the the first years of
building our families oh yes okay I
would start something it doesn't have to
be dramatic but I would start something
towards the kids college hundred dollars
a month or something in a good mutual
fund and that's going to be you know
that's gonna be a blast and get that
rolling and then everything else I'm
gonna throw towards the the mortgage
until it's paid off
I do want to get this mortgage paid off
as fast as possible regardless of the
zero percent interest rate and here's
the reason it's your largest payment and
as a matter of fact it's your only
payment and all the data tells us from
the ten thousand millionaires that we
surveyed that one of the keys to
becoming a millionaire is getting your
home paid off and keeping it paid off
okay and because it frees up cash now
you are in more of a danger zone then
you feel like you're in with this land
contract land contracts are very
dangerous here's why anything that
happens to your father-in-law or
mother-in-law who's named this property
is in and they get sued for that could
be a lien placed on the property that
you feel like you own that you do not
own if they are if they are driving down
the road and hit a patch of ice and they
were driving reasonably and someone gets
killed in the car wreck and Sue's them
for 500 million dollars and wins that
lien is gonna be placed on the property
that you thought you owned because it's
not in your name okay screw off if they
screw off and go run up a big IRS debt
and there's an IRS lien placed on them
it's going to be on that property that
they own that you have a contract to buy
contract for deed is a dangerous
ownership methodology point being you
could pay a hundred thousand dollars
down on this principle and 20 minutes
before you pay it off a lien gets
slapped on there
and you don't end up with the property
that you just paid off
in even if he wanted to I mean it could
be something that's out of his control
I'm not suggesting I was a crook
worst case scenario is he's crook but
I'm not suggesting that but I mean life
happens here and you can really get in a
mess so I strongly suggest that you guys
get that property put into your name and
you convert this from a land contract to
a mortgage on a mortgage or a deed of
trust depending on how your state
functions with a lien on a piece of
property that you own so the deed
transfers to you and you still owe him
under the exact same terms the mortgage
and if it costs a little bit of
paperwork money to get the lawyer to do
that you pay the bill and get it put
into your name before you start reducing
this principle and it has nothing to do
with questioning Papa's integrity life
happens and it could be out of Papa's
control and then you'd have a really bad
situation and believe me in 30 years
I've seen it a bunch and doing financial
counseling that's why I'm so strong on
it I hate land contracts